Усім привіт! Я Олена Оперчук.
І запрошую вас, шановні одинадцятикласники
на урок української літератури.
Ви дуже добре знаєте, що література
напряму пов’язана з історією.
Тож пам’ятаєте, що період з 1956 по 1964
отримав назву “відлига”.
З історії ви знаєте, що саме в 1956 році
Микита Хрущов своїм виступом засудив
режим Сталіна і репресії в тому числі.
Тож, саме в період правління Хрущова було
послаблено контроль за культурним життям.
Це сприяло неабиякому
творчому піднесенню.
Власне, по новому,
з новими силами заговорили
Максим Рильський,
Андрій Малишко, Володимир Сосюра.
Плюс до всього, власне, справжнє
оновлення мистецтва того часу
принесло покоління, яке
отримало назву “шістдесятники”.
Звертаю вашу увагу, що явище
шістдесятників було притаманне
всьому мистецтву:
і кіно, і музика, і
образотворче мистецтво.
Але саме в літературі
був найяскравіший спалах.
Тож, пригадаймо, а, можливо
дізнаймося (хто як вчився?!) –
особливості творчості шістдесятників.
Що ж їм було притаманно?
Перш за все – це
глибока інтелектуальність.
Плюс до всього – гуманістичні ідеї,
прагнення оновити поезією і будувати
її максимально на світових здобутках.
Також ми можемо
побачити і гумор, і сатиру,
і занурення в історію,
повернення до історії нашої країни.
Так ось, погляди і
прагнення шістдесятників –
вони суперечили
тогочасній ідеології, системі.
Тому і не дивно, що після
того, як почалися масові арешти,
заборона друкування – цей рух
припинив своє існування
у 1972 році.
Але ми з вами починаємо знайомитися
з найяскравішими представниками течії,
яка отримала назву шістдесятники.
В сьомому класі ви вивчали
твір. Пригадаймо його.
Ти знаєш, що ти – людина.
Ти знаєш про це чи ні?
Усмішка твоя – єдина,
Мука твоя – єдина,
Очі твої – одні.
Більше тебе не буде.
Завтра на цій землі
Інші ходитимуть люди,
Інші кохатимуть люди –
Добрі, ласкаві й злі.
Сьогодні усе для тебе –
Озера, гаї, степи.
І жити спішити треба,
Кохати спішити треба –
Гляди ж не проспи!
Бо ти на землі – людина,
І хочеш того чи ні –
Усмішка твоя – єдина,
Мука твоя – єдина,
Очі твої – одні.
Василь Симоненко
Тож сьогодні ми поговоримо саме
про творчість Василя Симоненка.
Власне, ви з нею знайомі – не те
що з сьомого, навіть з п’ятого класу,
коли вивчали віршову казку
«Цар Плаксій і Лоскотон».
Але це ще не все. Тож розпочинаємо!
Не докорю ніколи і нікому,
Хіба на себе інколи позлюсь,
Що в 20 літ в моєму серці втома,
Що в 30 – смерті в очі подивлюсь.
Моє життя – розтрощене корито,
І світ для мене – каторга і кліть...
Так краще в 30 повністю згоріти,
Ніж до півсотні помаленьку тліть.
Василь Симоненко прожив лише 28 років.
Але написав багато.
Його творча спадщина складає:
новели, поетичні твори,
оповідання, віршові казки і, навіть,
листи до сина – це теж
окремий вид мистецтва.
Дитинство Василя Симоненка
припало на воєнні роки.
Виховували його мама
та бабуся, а також дідусь.
Але, незважаючи на те,
що школа знаходилася за
багато-багато кілометрів від домівки,
він жодного разу не запізнився,
завжди був готовий до уроків.
І навіть погода його ніяк не зупиняла.
Тож закінчив школу Василь
Симоненко із золотою медаллю.
А після – вступив до омріяного вузу,
на факультет журналістики
до Київського Університету.
Якщо ж ми з вами будемо говорити про
Василя Симоненка,
то маємо запам’ятати, що
в літературі його називають
“витязь молодої української поезії”.
Можемо також у деяких джерелах знайти
– “лицар молодої української поезії’.
Саме так письменника
охарактеризував Олесь Гончар.
А Василь Стус сказав так:
“Він є найбільшим шістдесятником
серед шістдесятників”.
Життєве кредо Василя Симоненка
вміщено лише в чотирьох його рядках:
Ні перед ким не станеш спину гнути,
Не віддасися ворогу в ясу,
Якщо ти зміг, товаришу, збагнути
Свого народу велич і красу.
Власне, ця думка отримала своє продовження
в іншому творі Василя Симоненка,
з яким ви знайомилися в сьомому класі.
Мріють крилами з туману
Лебеді рожеві,
Сиплють ночі у лимани
Зорі сургучеві
Заглядає в шибу казка
Сивими очима,
Материнська добра ласка
В неї за плечима.
Ви всі їх впізнали,
оскільки вчили напам’ять.
Це – “Лебеді материнства”.
Хоча цей твір і не передбачено
програмою 11 класу,
пропоную його пригадати, адже він
виноситься на ЗНО, яке вам складати.
Тож пам’ятаймо, що «Лебеді материнства»
належать до громадянської лірики.
Можна в деяких джерелах зустріти,
що це ще й патріотична лірика.
Хоча мені особисто важко уявити, як можна
патріотичну лірику поєднати з колисковою.
Але, тим не менше.
Знову ж таки, літературні
критики відзначають,
що цей твір нагадує нам колискову
і його покладено на музику.
Композитором є Андрій Пашкевич.
Нагадую вам, шановні
одинадцятикласники, що темою твору є:
відтворення над колискою
дитини материнського співу,
у якому висловлюється тривога
за долю сина, чистоту його душі.
Адже мама нам співала колискову
не лише для того, аби заспокоїти,
а і через сон, скажімо так, виховати.
Якщо ж говорити про
основну думку цього твору,
то її ми можемо сказати словами
самого Василя Симоненка.
Зверніть увагу на екран.
Власне, все таки пропоную
вам все ж таки повернутися,
шановні одинадцятикласники,
до цього твору.
Його пригадати, перечитати, знайти
ключові образи.
Просто ЗНО ж не за горами.
Повернімося до тої
поезії, з якої я починала.
Ідеться про вірш “Ти
знаєш, що ти людина?”.
Ну, по-перше, зверніть, будь
ласка, увагу на розділові знаки –
раптом захочете це навести
як приклад з літератури.
Але, пригадаймо певні теоретичні поняття.
Перш за все – це стовідсоткова
філософська лірика.
Провідним мотивом є неповторність
кожної людини-особистості,
оскільки автор переконаний, що кожен
із нас – це особистість,
окремий космос.
Знову ж таки, деякі
літературні критики відзначають,
що цей твір, тобто вірш
“Ти знаєш, що ти людина?”
ми можемо назвати
гімном індивідуальності.
Перегляньте, будь ласка, його у вільну
хвилинку – він також виноситься на ЗНО.
А тепер пропоную розглянути
безпосередньо той твір,
який передбачено шкільною програмою.
І почнемо з елементарного – це назва:
“Задивляюсь у твої зіниці”.
Кожен із вас, той, хто ще
не знайомий із цим твором,
в принципі, може собі
уявити ту чи іншу картину.
Подумайте, будь ласка,
які у вас асоціації, а потім
перевіримо, розібравши даний твір.
Оскільки це вірш, тож рід – лірика.
А ось жанр, а жанр –
це громадянська лірика,
оскільки в даному творі Василь Симоненко
виражає свою синівську
любов до України-матері.
Тому, не інтимна, а
саме громадянська лірика.
Пропоную детальніше
ознайомитись з цим твором.
І, власне, визначитись, за допомогою
яких художніх засобів Василь Симоненко
намагався нам розповісти
про свої почуття до України.
Тож що ми з вами бачимо.
Увага на екран!
Що ми бачимо? Це, перш за все – епітети:
“… зіниці голубі й тривожні”, а
також “… червоні блискавиці”.
Це все також приправлено,
скажімо так, порівнянням “… ніби рань”.
З уроків мови ви пам’ятаєте,
що порівняльний зворот,
підрядна порівняльна під’єднується
сполучниками “як, мов, ніби”.
Тому і тут, коли ви будете
бачите слово “мов, ніби або як” –
ну, мабуть, відсотків 97
що це буде порівняння.
Ідемо далі.
Що ми бачимо з вами тут?
Оскільки митець у своєму творі
звертається до України, до рідної неньки,
тому в творі ми побачимо величезну
кількість риторичних звертань –
“тобто, нібито і в нікуди”,
але кожен з нас може зрозуміти
до кого ж звертається митець.
Тож в цих рядках ми бачимо з вами:
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Ідемо далі.
Не лише до рідних звертається у
своєму творі Василь Симоненко, а і:
“недруги лукаві”.
Але поруч і з ними стоять “друзі”.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу –
це також риторичне звертання.
“Нене” –
теж саме риторичне звертання.
Ви з попередніх уроків
літератури пам’ятаєте,
що в нас є три риторичних фігури:
риторичне питання, риторичний
оклик, риторичне звертання.
Зразки звертання ми вже з вами знайшли.
В цьому тексті також є риторичне
запитання, яке звучить так:
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Знову ж таки, оскільки автор
зізнається в любові своїй Україні-неньці,
тому слово Україна тут
трапляється не один раз.
Ось воно: "Україно..." –
риторичне звертання.
Пригадуємо з вами також єдинопочаток,
він же – анафора. Тож маємо:
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Але, аби показати наскільки
дорога для митця його ненька Україна,
він використовує ще такий художній засіб,
який називається метонімія.
І виражено його в рядках
“Хай мовчать Америки й
Росії, коли я з тобою говорю”.
І, власне, в останніх рядках
ми з вами бачимо перш за все також:
анафору -"Хай...Хай...",
і літоту – це применшення.
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Запам’ятайте, будь ласка, в
цьому творі найважливіші речі,
ключові речі, низку риторичних запитань.
Пригадуйте, будь ласка, про метонімію.
І перейдімо до наступного твору,
який має доволі цікаву назву
“Я”.
Так ось, щодо цього
“Я” існують різні думки.
Але це дуже гарний приклад
того як ми маємо ставитися до тих,
хто нас оточує. Отже, поезія “Я”.
Сподіваюсь, вона у вас перед очима.
Що ми маємо? Класичний початок.
Рід – лірика.
Жанр – філософська лірика.
Провідний мотив –
це утвердження думки, що кожен із нас є
неповторним і непересічною особистістю.
Власне, в цьому творі звучить заклик
поважати тих, хто
знаходиться навколо нас.
І, відповідно, тут ми з вами
бачимо ліричного героя і
такого собі опонента-бюрократа,
який прагне принизити людську гідність.
Спробуємо розібрати даний твір,
проаналізувати його і знайти оте “Я”.
Що ж воно означає? Тож – до роботи!
“Він дивився на мене тупо
очицями, повними блекоти”
художній засіб “метафора”. Ви про
це знаєте, так само як пам’ятаєте,
що під видом метафори є також
персоніфікація, уособлення і так далі.
В наступних рядках (увага на екран!)
ми з вами бачимо епітет
– це теж саме художнє
означення. Без нього – нікуди.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу!
В першому рядку одночасно
вміщено два художніх засоби.
Перш за все – це
персоніфікація і художній прийом,
який також знаходить відображення в мові.
Йдеться про інверсію – неправильний
порядок слів. Як ми бачимо з вами:
“гордість не стала навколішки”
– підмет стоїть після присудка.
Плюс – означення “моя” не перед
означувальним словом ”гордість”,
а після нього.
В наступному (другому) рядку
ми також бачимо з вами метафору.
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Можливо, хтось міг би
сказати, що тут є і порівняння,
тому що “хвилини”
порівнюються з ”отарою”.
В принципі – ні, тому що немає
звичних для нас з вами сполучників.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу –
в наступному першому рядку
слово “Я” написане, по-перше, в
лапках; по-друге, з великої літери,
оскільки автор наголошує на
тому, що ми є – індивідуальність
і маємо з гордістю нести
ім’я людина, своє ім’я.
І бути, найважливіше, собою
– єдиними і неповторними.
Зверніть, будь ласка,
увагу на ось цю цитату:
“Ми – не безліч стандартних “я”,
а безліч всесвітів різних“.
Ми єдині і неповторні.
Зверніть увагу на два останні рядки.
Ми бачимо єдинопочаток
(анафору) і епітети.
"...океанна вселюдська сім'я."
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу–
це моє слово “висновок“,
тому що літературні критики
відзначають, що наприкінці свого твору
Василь Симоненко сам
же і робить висновок:
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Недарма в народі кажуть: “Стався до людей
так, як ти хочеш, щоб ставилися до тебе!“.
Тож дотримуємося, будь
ласка, цих правил і пам’ятайте –
кожен із нас єдиний і неповторний.
Пам’ятайте і не забувайте.
Тож, власне, й все. Перейдімо до
найважливішого пункту будь-якого уроку,
а саме – домашнє завдання.
Зверніть увагу на екран!
Аби зануритися в
епоху, в якій жив митець –
перегляньте фільми, назву
яких ви бачите на екрані!
На YouTube ви також знайдете
авторське дуже цікаве читання поезії
“Задивляюсь у твої зіниці …”
Чимала кількість творів також
покладена на сучасну музику.
Особисто мені подобається.
Тому пропоную (раптом
захочете, або буде вільна хвилинка)
послухати два останні твори,
назву яких ви бачите на екрані.
Тож насолоджуйтеся красою слова і
до наступних зустрічей! До побачення!